so this is kind of the perfect storm for
you because
we get to talk about movies and video
games
our topic today is rotten tomatoes wrong
about the tomato meter when it comes to
video game movies
on it so we're going to kind of set it
up but before we get to all that
what is your favorite video game movie
of
all time
there's a lot of good ones a lot of bad
ones uh
i'm only a lot of bad ones i'm probably
i'm going to say i'm going to say the
original mortal kombat
it's an incredible movie it's in a time
where
movies uh in action movies specifically
were so
such a part of everyone's life in pop
culture mortal kombat stood out because
it was the most perfectly cast movie i
think i've ever seen
because then you look at like street
fighter of the movie the most horribly
casted movie
except for raul julia rogers incredible
honda was okay but it wasn't like samoan
like which is which is like fine
but um what are you ken and ryu are both
like 20 pounds and like they're great
probably great dudes but like
that's not what are y'all doing with
this and then you look at mortal kombat
casting
flawless flawless i'll tell you and and
we said this when when we
we covered mortal kombat in an entire
episode of this show and i've just never
replicated the chills i got as a kid in
the movie theater
when you see sub-zero and scorpion
emerge from
the green room wherever they were
warming up in the locker room
and they come out and because you
wrestle in
occasionally immortal combat gear i
imagine you have the same kind of
feeling
when you're walking to the ring and you
have that
sort of regalia on it's got to be like
you're living out a lifelong fantasy yes
so when i was in college
one of my roommates uh junior and senior
year uh we we both loved mortal kombat
and at least like two or three times a
week
we would turn it on and play that scene
where sonia goes down into the bottom of
the boat and she sees shang tsung in the
chains
and when they come out of the about like
you said the locker room and that music
the drums
opens the door and they're standing
there the first time you see him and
then all of a sudden it's that side shot
which i love which i love they hit the
flying v
and the scorpion in and then sub-zero
comes in on the side and
that's that's a movie right there that's
a movie
and i have a totally different i love
that movie i absolutely do but i have
this thing for
christopher lambert who's like this huge
french movie star and the very first
movie class i ever took was a french
cinema class um
back when i was a french major he is
having so much fun in that movie
and he's almost in a different movie
like he's like he's like given the
business into this fight for the death i
love it and like when you read the
backstory of him with that he was
basically like
yeah i'll only do the movie if we do it
in thailand where we can get drunk and
then just got drunk with the cast
all night and like they just like had a
bit of a party i also
agree with you mortal kombat is up there
i want to ask you though like
how do you feel about the sequel because
i think i'm the lone person who has
this like it's so bad i actually still
enjoy it with annihilation
are you just like writing it off so
there's the thing so um
when i was young one of the ways that my
dad and i would bond would be going to
the movies like and just watching stuff
and we
really enjoyed it and so when we just
see mortal kombat
he loved it he knew how like i played
the game and stuff and so he like knew a
little bit about the characters but
after saw the movie was like man this is
great
and then we heard annihilation was
coming out and it was like what we get
the second one that's gonna be so dope
and as soon as the movie started and
they killed johnny cage
thank you as a child a child who doesn't
understand these like
weird concepts i knew something was
wrong and i stood up
and i walked out and you know who was
right behind me
just as mad as i was my dad
who who kills johnny cage in the first
30 seconds of the movie who does this
miss molina with like the la you die
now i'm sorry the line reads on that
would give tommy wiseau
like goosebumps it is so bad
that you i am you have to lean into it
team here
i i will be his tag team partner going
to the mat against annihilation because
i was so excited in the theater
i was with my friends and i actually
yelled out mortal kombat i don't suggest
that kind of jackassery but when the new
line cinema stuff comes in i yelled
mortal kombat and some people
have some people told me to shut up and
then the movie starts and again within
10 minutes
i wish i was with you and your old man
we could just walk out of the theater
because
it was just such a crappy movie
experience so i'll tell you what we're
going to do
we are going to to break down just the
10 best
video game movies according to the
tomato meter so
we do get to hear mortal kombat mortal
kombat annihilation nowhere near the top
ten
thank the good lord on high can i ask
you a question huh so i this is
not really the question anymore
statements i'm looking at the rotten
tomatoes website right now
and i see and i'm i'm really upset this
has nothing to do with what we're going
to talk about but i have to get it out
my favorite movie of all time has a
rating of
15 on the tomato meter oof
what is your favorite movie disgusted i
am disgusted with the people that have
put this
trash on their website how dare you rate
white chicks solo
how dare you that is the greatest movie
of all
time a full cinematic experience you
have everything you have drama
you have jokes you have happiness
sadness you have incredible soundtrack
you have an incredible actor you have
so many so many it's an undercover
thriller as well
an undercover thriller because they look
terrifying
and t and terry crews is singing vanessa
carl out i guess
i guess this is the thing this is why we
have the show austin
increase why we have the show put that
at least to an 85
i can't but you can come back on and
rail against it we'll get you and terry
crews to tag team about it because he
honestly talks about how that movie
changed not only his career but his life
and all because he leaned into a song
you you telling me we got 11 land before
times i can't get a white chicks too why
why uh why do we not have 62 how because
they
because they need to make another
pikachu movie let's break down this list
real quick though
and seriously though now you're now
you're right based on the video game
it's not it's not but i would see that
video game
no let's let's break it down though too
because and by the way austin you have
officially agreed to come back and talk
about why chicks don't know if you know
that but i'm
absolutely gonna make that happen but
here we go so we'll talk about the top
10 list because
for a very long time mortal kombat was
the top one
with 47 was 47
correct yeah uh yeah 44
44 47 now we have angry birds 2 at 73
percent pikachu is at 67
and sonic at 63. so the top three films
and the only three fresh ones
have come in the past three years um we
also had two films in 19
uh sorry in 2018 who i had a 50
rating that's being rampage and tomb
raider
i personally like this sort of
top 10 list um but yeah it's
it's it's interesting to to kind of
think that it didn't make it that far
i don't know what do you think about it
it's a lot of people argue that the
angry birds movie is not
really a video game movie
if we break it down by semantics yes but
there's not like an angry birds
story from the game that could be
translated to the movie really
like an extremely loose one but like it
semantics wise yes it's technically a
video game movie
uh but i feel like that's why mortal
kombat works so well as a
as a movie and that's why i'm so pumped
for the new one to come out is because
mortal kombat is that sweet spot of a
video game where
we're attached to the characters but the
story it
it's like we know it's a fighting
tournament it's like march madness
yeah for this sort of martial arts
combat that is
intergalactic and so we all go into the
movie knowing that with angry birds
there's like
you don't really care about any of the
characters and so the storytellers had
the freedom to do
whatever the hell they wanted yeah do
you think that's better do you think
that's better
i mean it's kind of like it makes me
think about like the trolls movie
there's not like a story line with the
trolls movie they just kind of like when
like oh we can make a movie about music
oh let's use the trolls to tell it which
is and they're
incredible movies especially world tour
but like angry birds
and i don't want to sound like i'm a
gatekeeper like oh they're not like real
gamers like it's it's a video game that
people enjoy and so they made a movie so
it's a video game movie but
i don't i don't remember there being a
narrative or like characters that i'm
like oh
this is my character from the game that
i'm obsessed with and i'm excited to see
translated into a movie
so like i don't know if there's a way to
work that into the definition but then
does that disqualify certain things
i'm not sure i'm not the authority on it
but so i i'm gonna go pretty
loose with my definition of what
constitutes a video game movie but i
also
since your champion is mortal kombat i
jacqueline and i are gonna pick two
different ones and i just wanna
use you as a sounding board and you tell
me what your
what your gut reaction to this is
because i'm gonna defend
a movie that's not even in the top 10 of
the tomato meter video game flicks
and that would be warcraft because
warcraft
even though it didn't completely pull
off the magic trick
but there was so much to do
in that movie and there was just so many
places you could have taken the story so
the fact that duncan jones gave us a
competent narrative and some characters
to care about
i thought that was an achievement and it
should be at least in the top ten
yeah i agree with you on that one i'll
give you that until we find something
that bumps it up
can you find something that bumps it out
look we already talked about warcraft i
think that movie was done with somebody
who absolutely
loved the game the director duncan jones
was very clear about that was the reason
why
he did this and he was coming off a moon
the man could have literally kind of
made whatever movie that he wanted and
he wanted to make
a big hulking orc homage to world of
warcraft and i think it's
it's really interesting that he did it
and it's it made a ton of money
people like lose that 28 but it made a
ton of money and it had a really great
audience score
i actually have one that is way lower
and i don't think it's going to defeat
warcraft as far as love but i have love
for it because
this is also the game that got me back
into gaming because i think
for some people it's like after a
certain age or at least with me
i kind of got into other things i was
doing like theater and choir and so
gaming like took a back seat i would say
in like
high school and late middle school but
then in college
i really picked up on assassin's creed
again and so that movie
like game even though it's horrible
i still loved the the earnestness of it
of them trying to marry the craziness
it's still
something i think that could be done
better in a different form but yeah i
i like i like assassin's creed with a
special honorable mention to the super
mario
brothers movie for being so bad it's
good see i like so bad it's good movie
that's the take
i won xavier yeah yay or nay
on the super mario brothers movie from
1999
dude do you realize the range that
john leguizamo has dude in that scene
when they're
there are they talking to the police and
he goes uh what's your name he goes
mario mario who was what's your name
luigi mario i was like
of course his last name is mario those
are the mario brothers but mario's name
is mario
like that as a child like that that
blows my mind until this day that
like i didn't realize that his name
would be luigi mario and mario mario
um that and that alone and then the
scene with the goomba when he's all sad
and stuff like come on but then that
reminds me a similar scene in double
dragon
when dude who's all messed up gets sad
in the mirror like that's also a very
good video game movie
that we don't really talk about in these
kind of conversations yeah robert
patrick
was the bad guy in and double dragon 2
particularly it was my brother and his
favorite video game to team up and play
together where you were billy and jimmy
lee going through the the mean streets
and the movie came i don't know that i
ever have actually seen double dragon i
will give that one a second look
i will give that one a chance and that's
that's why i'm weird about the
definition because like
if you say double dragon the movie you
automatically go oh my god my memories
of this game and having so much fun with
people playing it but you go
hey angry birds the movie i don't i'm
sure there is someone but i've never met
them that goes
oh angry birds is my jam i can't wait
for this movie on all the sweet
narratives they bring from the game to
the movie like
who's who's saying that i want to meet
them so i'm very curious
[Music]
you